looks like now as if life has stopped
because most of its citizens have left
the sounds of shelling are almost
non-stop reminding us here there are
Fierce battles taking place on the
outskirts of the city the shells hit
homes markets infrastructure facilities
and even the main sports Stadium
the bridges connecting two parts of the
city have been damaged forcing many
residents to make dangerous trips for
humanitarian aid from the leaf
organizations that dare to enter the
city
we have managed to bring food and some
Necessities there is no water
electricity or gas in the city
Communications are cut off bombing is
ongoing the situation is difficult and
we advise people to leave the city
before the winter intensifies
Eleanor won't leave her City she refuses
to speak on camera at her age she
doesn't want to become a refugee we met
Andre and his wife they went out to
inspect Apartments of some of their
friends who have left the city
if we look around what can we say we
live amid these terrifying sounds of
explosions but we were born here and we
want to die here
foreign front is described as having the
fiercest fighting in the denetsk region
Ukrainian forces are trying to repel
repeated Russian attempts to storm the
city from three directions with moscow's
forces only about three kilometers away
for nearly four months Russian soldiers
have been trying to take over bakmud to
open the way to sloviance and chromatosk
the two most important cities still
under control of Ukrainian forces in
Donetsk province